what would you advise me
from politics
how can we better help young entrepreneurs
what do you think of the business climate
entrepreneurs are bullied 1 bit
in the Netherlands
I notice especially with many large entrepreneurs
I am not very big already
but really those great entrepreneurs
who move a lot to other countries
also within Europe
so it is not the European Union
but really purely to the Netherlands
I think tax is very high anyway
The Netherlands plus the regulatory burden is also virtually
for example if I want to hire 1 employee
I did that 1 while ago
and then you go through the whole process
you get all those laws
healthcare costs I know a lot about everything
well there will be 40 by the way
on top of the agreed salary
saves that I don't want to pay 40 extra
and if he wants to arrange his own pension
by just investing
in shares for each month
which also works much better than his pension fund I think
so why would you hand that over to
joint pension fund